bonjour et je vous en prie
installez-vous savez-vous même lesquels
de la fosse installez-vous bonjour
Olivier merci beaucoup d'être là et vous
êtes notre invité politique ce matin
Michael de la fosse Mercus Montpellier
président de Montpellier Méditerranée
métropole en étant ça pendant 20 minutes
pour une interview en partenariat avec
la presse régionale et on est ravi
d'accueillir Olivier Biscay bonjour
merci beaucoup d'être là directeur de la
rédaction du Midi Libre votre presse
locale évidemment Michael de la façon à
parler de la réforme des retraites pour
commencer ce qui arrive aujourd'hui au
Sénat qu'attendez-vous des sénateurs
que le débat est le lieu sur l'ensemble
des articles en particulier sur
l'article 7 pour lequel je soutiendrai
la position des sénateurs de gauche et
en particulier du président Patrick
Canet il faut qu'il y a un vote et la
gauche votre acompte le report de l'âge
légal à 64 ans mais il faut que ce vote
ait lieu pour que le pays connaissent
les positions des uns et des autres et
j'espère que le Sénat mais je n'en doute
pas aura beaucoup plus de respect de
l'exercice démocratique que le triste
spectacle qui s'est livré à l'Assemblée
nationale qui n'a pas tiré vers le haut
le débat démocratique et parfois regardé
par les adolescents par les jeunes et je
suis pas sûr qu'il soit allé chercher un
bon exemple mais sur le fond il faut
entendre la colère sociale qui s'exprime
dans les cortèges trading une unité
syndicale inédite depuis le CPE
et il faut que le chef de l'État
comprenne que là on ne gouverne pas sur
des principes d'injustice on va revenir
sur la forme et sur ce qui s'est passé à
l'Assemblée mais restons sur le sur le
fond un vote sur l'article 7 vous le
souhaitez vous souhaitez en vote sur
l'ensemble du texte mais bien sûr
c'est comme ça que fonctionne notre
démocratie et la responsable la gauche
ne soutient pas ce texte mais elle doit
dire ce qu'elle propose les alternatives
parce que nous notre responsabilité
c'est de donner un chemin différent pays
nous avons la conviction que bien sûr il
faut réformer notre régime de retraite
pour protéger le modèle par répartition
mais que ça ne peut pas se faire par un
impôt de deux ans sur la vie des gens
c'est qui jusqu'au bout parce que la
gauche c'est notoriale n'est pas une
anime là-dessus
qu'il faut débattre faut dire qui est
pour qui est contre et si on est contre
qu'est-ce qu'on propose c'est quel point
ils peuvent apporter peut-être apporter
des modifications quels sont les points
que les socialistes faire
[Musique]
doivent partir à la retraite plus tôt ce
dont l'espérance de vie est plus longue
c'est normal qu'il cotise plus longtemps
et ça ce contrat social tout le monde
peut l'entendre ça s'appelle gouverner
dans un esprit de justice et de
responsabilités plus loin qu'est-ce
qu'il faut faire
mais les femmes c'est on peut pas dire
dans notre pays que la grande cause
c'est l'égalité femme homme et ne pas
être au rendez-vous sur cette réforme
des retraites pour garantir des pensions
pour les femmes qui ont eu souvent des
carrières hachées moins bien rémunérées
que les hommes à 1200 euros et le député
Jérôme Guedj a fait un travail
remarquable au Parlement pour lever les
lièvres des propos qui étaient tenus en
disant tout va bien pour les femmes non
il y a des réalités donc là il faut que
nous allions de l'avant la réalité des
des femmes c'est des carrières hachées
souvent moins bien rémunéré que les que
les hommes et puis une réalité qui
arrive c'est les femmes seules avec
enfants et un autre pays doit prendre la
mesure de cette
vulnérabilité sociale et le texte là
peut sans doute s'améliorer et je ne
doute pas que le gouvernement sera
sensible aux arguments de la gauche sur
ce sujet enfin j'invite le gouvernement
nous invitons le gouvernement à entendre
et mobilisations sociales dans la rue la
gauche parlementaire qui en tout cas
pour les socialistes s'expriment avec
responsabilité proposition contre
proposition un texte on n'a jamais
raison tout seul un mot sur un dernier
mot sur les femmes parce que Bruno
retailleur le président du groupe les
républicains ici au Sénat veut que les
femmes qui ont trois enfants ou plus et
une carrière complète puissent partir de
manière anticipée ou avec une surcote
Olivier dussobe c'est dit d'accord et
ouvert est-ce que les sénateurs
socialistes doivent voter c'est
à eux de se déterminer ça me semble être
une mesure positive mais je pense qu'il
faut pas juste prendre le seul critère
du nombre d'enfants par femme il faut
prendre la réalité des parcours qu'on
vécu les femmes dans leur carrière bien
moins payés que les hommes 25% c'est un
des
injustices que nous constatons que nous
dénonçons trouvons des réponses prendre
la mesure parfois des situations de
précarité professionnelle qu'elles ont
vécu donc là il y a une approche à avoir
et peut-être on pourrait envoyer un
signal politique très fort à l'occasion
de l'examen au Sénat pour donner une
démonstration de l'égalité femme homme
Michael de la fosse les syndicats la
SNCF appelle à nos grève reconductible à
partir du 7 mars est-ce que vous la
soutenez moi je suis très respectueux
des organisations syndicales premier
point elles sont unies
deuxième point les cortèges se déroulent
dans une grande dignité avec beaucoup de
responsabilités il y a pas de casse il y
a pas de violence c'est notre démocratie
sociale les organisations de syndicales
déterminent leur stratégie et si elles
en sont maintenant obligés à appeler à
une grève reconductible ça veut dire
qu'elles n'ont pas le sentiment d'être
écouté et je le dis très très clairement
on ne peut pas
mépriser les hommes et les femmes qui
s'engagent dans leur entreprise dans les
services publics à travers leurs
organisations syndicales il faut savoir
faire des compromis il faut inviter les
partenaires sociaux à Matignon il faut
faire un pas sinon le pays va peut
connaître des blocages ce que personne
ne souhaite les gens ils font jamais
grève par plaisir vous perdez une
journée de salaire c'est dur donc il
faut écouter et qu'est-ce que vous
demandez concrètement vous demandez au
gouvernement de retirer sa réforme et de
se remettre autour de la table avec les
moi je pense que ça c'est indispensable
enfin Laurent Berger et Philippe
Martinez font preuve d'un esprit de très
grandes responsabilités et l'ensemble
des leaders syndicaux à force Ouvrière
la CGC l'une ça Laurent Escure et
d'autres et donc notre démocratie elle
est parlementaire le débat s'ouvre Sénat
mais elle doit être aussi sociale si on
n'écoute pas les organisations
syndicales les corps intermédiaires les
corps constitués mais qu'est-ce comment
va fonctionner notre pays je crois que
c'est très important et donc il est
temps de de reprendre le chemin des
négociations je voudrais le dire c'est
un fait inédit cette unité syndicale la
dernière fois c'était au moment du CPE
est-ce qu'on a envie que le pays se
bloque est-ce qu'on a envie de voir les
tensions s'accroître je le dis il y a un
enjeu de responsabilité
mais le blocage le gouvernement ne
retira pas sa réforme vous le savez bien
j'espère qu'il va faire preuve de
sagesse et de responsabilité
à l'image des organisations syndicales
enfin si la stratégie du gouvernement
c'est le blocage du pays
c'est pas bon pour notre économie c'est
pas bon pour l'emploi il faut entendre
il faut entendre quand l'ensemble des
syndicats sont unis ça dit quelque chose
et d'ailleurs la dernière fois il y a
une grande mobilisation sociale c'était
le CPE et bien un moment le président
Chirac il a entendu il a dit on arrête
le CPE parce que quand près de 75% des
Français disent nous ne sommes pas
d'accord avec cette réforme des
retraites là il faut entendre il ne faut
pas marcher il faut pas chercher à faire
un acte
d'autoritarisme parce qu'on en est
quasiment là
c'est d'autoritarisme pour vous je te
fais Emmanuel Macron ben je pense que
quand on ne prend pas la mesure des
nombreuses journées de grève qui se
tiennent dans le calme quand on ne prend
pas la mesure de cette unité syndicale
quand on voit les sondages d'opinion qui
disent quand même des choses on fait
attention voilà et cette réforme elle
est injuste elle demande à elle dit tout
le monde part à 64 ans alors que des
gens ont une espérance de vie inférieure
à 64 à tout le monde certes mais
pardonnez-moi mais ce sont les gens
qu'on a qualifié des métiers essentiels
porno le covid c'est ce que nous avons
applaudis vous savez les ripeurs les
gens mettaient des post-it sur les
poubelles pour leur dire merci d'être là
les personnels qui dans les écoles ont
fait face pour assurer la continuité
éducative tout ça et le et la
reconnaissance du pays après cet épisode
du covid c'est travailler deux ans de
plus
il faut pas être uniforme voilà vous
parlez de sagesse et de responsabilité
venons-en peut-être la France insoumise
vous les avez un peu dénoncé en ce début
d'interview comment vous avez jugé
l'attitude de la France insoumise à
l'Assemblée nationale anti-républicaine
anti-démocratique
revendique le populisme de gauche
à l'Assemblée le Sénat comme l'Assemblée
nationale ce sont des lieux de
l'éloquence des lieux où par le verbe on
expose ses idées et on oppose la
contradiction il y a eu au Sénat ou à
l'Assemblée nationale des grands moments
d'éloquence ce n'est pas le lieu de
loutrans on peut avoir des désaccords
politiques mais on traite pas un
ministre d'assassin on ne caricature pas
et je suis
je le dis la gauche
ne peut pas être cela et d'ailleurs si
elle continue à être cela elle est
condamnée à témoigner et pas à être une
force d'alternance pour améliorer la vie
des gens et donc désolidariser de la
France insoumise pour vous ah mais pour
moi il est très clair que si les
socialistes composent avec des forces
d'outrances qui font l'éloge de la
violence qui applaudit monsieur catenin
qui a été condamné par la justice parce
que il a battu sa femme mais on va pas
s'en sortir les gens ils veulent de la
clarté mais donc vous dites il faut
mettre fin à la nuque dès maintenant
moi je dis ce que nous devons faire je
dis que notre opposition elle doit être
une opposition
résolue par exemple sur le projet de
réforme des retraites une force de
proposition et qu'on peut défendre ses
idées dans le cadre d'un débat
républicain argument contre argument
il y a un vote
et Madame projet a été soutenue par les
militants socialistes beaucoup des lieux
locaux
l'Ariège et bien les électeurs ont le
choix entre une candidate mais un projet
qui sera contre la retraite à 65 ans qui
sera pour soutenir de manière résolue
l'Ukraine et qui le fera avec conviction
mais loin de l'outrans est loin du
populisme et moi je je crois qu'il faut
la soutenir et si elle était moins bien
placée que l'autre candidat de gauche et
bien on appellera au second tour à voter
pour mes je le dis très clairement je le
dis très clairement si la gauche compose
avec le populisme si elle a des phrases
comme la police tue alors que nos
policiers nous protègent et bien elle
est condamnée à témoigner et moi je
souhaite que la gauche puisse créer les
conditions d'un rassemblement qui puisse
donner des perspectives de justice à
notre pays pour ça cette stratégie
d'union avec la nuque a bien été valider
par les militants socialistes et très
largement autour d'Olivier Faure
qu'est-ce que vous dites de ce vote des
militants très largement Olivier Faure
il y a plus que 20000 adhérents Parti
socialiste j'en suis encore parce que je
suis fidèle ils ont voté oui oui
d'accord ils ont voté et ça s'est passé
de manière ricraque et beaucoup de nos
sympathisants
socialiste beaucoup de gens qui ne sont
pas socialisme et qui ont du respect
pour ce qu'est ce grand courant de la
vie politique française qui parfois a
traduit désespérance par moment à déçu
mais qui n'a pas un moment on s'est
retrouvé dans cette situation
ne peut pas aller composer avec des
forces qui se réclament d'un populisme
avec le populisme dans l'Ariège par
exemple lui il soutient pas la même
candidate que vous fait de l'accord
je lui dis sur votre plateau il a tort
parce que dans l'Ariège il n'y a pas de
risque d'extrême droite et que à un
moment il faut que la gauche elle
s'affirme en fidélité à son histoire
dans le respect des valeurs
démocratiques en fidélité à nos idéaux
républicains elle doit être claire sur
les questions de laïcité de respect du
débat démocratique et donc les électeurs
ils ont le choix il y a quelqu'un qui
peut applaudir monsieur catenens quand
il revient à l'Assemblée nationale il y
a quelqu'un qui peut cautionner qu'on
traite un ministre d'assassin ou une
député une candidate socialiste à un
projet qui elle votera résolument contre
la réforme des retraites qui le fera
dans le respect du débat républicain et
quand à gauche et dans cette attitude là
et bien elle inspire la confiance et
donc il y a une perspective de victoire
pour elle si elle se complètent dans le
populisme elle sera condamnée à
témoigner pendant longtemps sur les
bancs de l'opposition ça peut intéresser
Monsieur Mélenchon ça peut intéresser un
certain nombre de leaders politiques
mais les socialistes je crois que leurs
devoirs c'est de s'opposer de proposer
et quand ils sont responsabilités comme
nous à Montpellier ben de faire la
gratuité des transports d'agir contre
les logements insalubre d'avoir des
positions claires sur la laïcité sur la
sécurité il y a donc de gauche
irréconciliables pas du tout ah bon
la gauche elle a toujours eu des débats
mais il y a une gauche qui ne doit pas
se taire c'est celle des socialistes et
elle ne doit pas se mettre à l'ombre
d'un populiste elle doit être dans la
clarté moi je m'adresse aux électeurs
aux hommes et femmes de gauche et il y a
un peuple de gauche et celui-là
n'espérez pas le diviser en deux ça
c'est nos adversaires et ensuite dans la
gauche la question est quelle est la
stratégie et si on pense que la
stratégie populiste est une stratégie
gagnante moi je dis c'est en train de
perdre sa culture de gouvernement je dis
que c'est une impasse non parce que le
Parti socialiste a beaucoup d'élus qui
eux exercent des responsabilités et fort
heureusement et nos administrer le
savent ne se livrent pas à ce type
d'exercice populiste et quand le PS des
élus socialistes dirigent des
collectivités et ils changent la vie des
gens vous aviez un débat sur les
médecins tout à l'heure très intéressant
tu es pas d'accord avec même la
présidente mais c'est le débat
républicain oui moi je soutiens Carole
Delga et ben SCARL delgals salariée des
médecins et elle essaye de les installer
dans des zones rurales c'est une élue
socialiste qui change la vie des gens
moi je suis un maire socialiste quand on
fait la gratuité des transports dans le
contexte d'inflation qui est le nôtre
nous agissons et nous agissons sur les
questions écologiques pour laquelle
notre jeunesse est à juste titre
exigeante je pourrais prendre plein
d'autres exemples de socialisme qui ont
une culture de responsabilité pour
changer la vie des gens PS parce qu'il y
a une nouvelle gouvernance qui a été
mise en place Olivier forêt donc été élu
1er secrétaire et Nicolas may Rossignol
que vous souteniez a été je soutiens
ardemment
il est premier secrétaire délégué ça
marche bien cette nouvelle gouvernance
[Musique]
non mais je préfère
comment le dire il est temps que le
collectif reprenne force voilà et
Nicolas meilleur rossignol est un
excellent maire de Rouen vous l'avez
invité sur ce plateau l'entend il porte
très bien certains membres de valeur et
je crois que
Monsieur fort a tout intérêt à
travailler de manière claire avec lui
pour avancer sinon ça va pas fonctionner
voilà vous avez dit
il faut qu'il fasse un peu plus
d'efforts Olivier
vous avez dit votre attachement aux
parties socialiste vous a eu envie de le
quitter ces dernières semaines et de
faire autre chose à une autre
orientation
moi je suis au PS depuis 30 ans je suis
attaché le courant socialiste
a façonner l'histoire de France comme le
courant de la droite
Chateaubriand Victor Hugo il y a des
grandes figures de la droite
parlementaire des grandes figures de la
gauche parlementaire moi je ne crois pas
ou en même temps je ne crois pas à la
confusion des esprits comme quoi tout se
vaut alors les socialistes ils sont en
petite forme en ce moment mais
nous savons nous avons une histoire
cette histoire beaucoup de Français
d'ailleurs nous disent souvent vous avez
quand même fait des choses incroyables
on va fêter les 10 ans du mariage pour
tous aujourd'hui la CMU est une évidence
les 35 heures sont là tout ça
l'éducation et le premier budget de la
Nation tout ça on le doit à
socialiste et aujourd'hui nous la
question est la suivante c'est qu'est-ce
que nous pouvons proposer pour que ce
pays notre pays que nous aimons la
France soit plus fort et plus juste
travaillons et donc moi ne comptez pas
sur moi pour quitter ce grand courant
qui est le courant socialiste à
condition qu'il soit dans la clarté sur
son attachement la République sur la
question de la laïcité des services
publics la lutte contre les inégalités
les questions de sécurité qui sont très
importantes pour les Français les plus
fragiles qui subissent un civilité au
quotidien qui doivent sentir qu'ils sont
protégés dernier point peut-être le
Salon de l'Agriculture puisque vous êtes
présent la métropole de Montpellier est
présente au salon l'une des inquiétudes
de l'agriculteurs c'est la sécheresse
hivernale record qui frappe le pays
Christophe béchulministre alerté hier
sur la situation dans trois régions dont
la vôtre l'Occitanie appelle les préfets
de ne pas avoir la main qui tremble pour
prendre des mesures de restriction d'eau
il a raison
mais je vais vous dire comme président
de la métropole nous avons fait des
choix pour protéger l'eau d'abord on a
fait une régie publique de l'eau et de
l'assainissement parce qu'il faut que il
y ait un contrôle de ce commun le
deuxième point nous venons de mettre en
place un tarif déco solidarité de l'eau
plus vous consommerez d'eau plus vous
paierez cher parce que l'eau consommée
de manière illimitée ça n'est plus
possible par contre pour les plus
fragiles et bien là nous avons mis en
place les 15 premiers mètres cubes d'eau
gratuit voilà comment nous agissons à
Montpellier en ce moment
même mon signe vous êtes la bienvenue il
y a beaucoup de travaux je le dis nous
devons c'est pas populaire de faire des
travaux mais quand vous avez vos tuyaux
percés parce que les réseaux d'Adia 50
ans vous gaspillez la ressource donc il
faut rénover et enfin et je le dis à
Monsieur Béchu je le dis à Monsieur
Béchu il faut nous aider la
réglementation est trop complexe il faut
que nous puissions réutiliser l'eau qui
provient de l'assainissement pour
nettoyer les rues des villes sans doute
pour les usages agricoles Paul Valéry
disait le temps du monde finit commence
et bien en matière d'eau c'est le cas et
donc moi j'entends ce que dit le
ministre mais surtout au niveau local
nous agissons nous agissons pour
préserver cette ressource qui est
indispensable un petit mot Oriane
peut-être sur Montpellier culture
Montpellier capitale culturel européenne
2028 vous portez en 2000 votre badge sur
la veste de votre costume ça démarre
c'est tout près c'est demain c'est
mercredi 1er jury demain c'est le grand
oral devant le jury
issu de la Commission européenne de la
ministre de la Culture et c'est une
aventure formidable il y a 9 villes
engagés 9 territoires et nous nous le
faisons et je veux le dire ici
solennellement nous le faisons comme un
plaidoyer pour la culture en ce moment
il y a un homme qui s'appelle Vladimir
Poutine qui a déclenché la guerre en
Europe mais qui a bombardé le théâtre de
Mario Paul qui a anéanti 240 lieu de
culture en Ukraine alors dans cette
guerre qui est terrible pour laquelle
nous devons être aux côtés des
Ukrainiens et bien nous notre devoir
c'est d'essayer de rallumer des lumières
autour de la créativité la liberté des
artistes c'est le faire à Montpellier
comme d'autres villes le font c'est une
fidélité à ce qu'est notre pays la
France la liberté c'est le faire en
disant aux obscurantistes
parce que au nom de votre religion vous
tuez des artistes et bien nous nous
répondons nous accueillons des artistes
nous les défendons et se plaidoyer il
faut le porter alors peut-être
Montpellier sera retenu avec nos amis de
scène de la force évidemment
pour gagner mais je le dis il nous faut
vous m'interrogez toujours socialiste je
n'oublierai jamais ce qu'on était les
combats fondateurs de François
Mitterrand en faveur de la culture et je
j'observe que s'il y a quelques mères de
droite qui postulent il y a beaucoup de
maire de gauche qui s'engagent
Olivia oui absolument on parle du
Médiator aujourd'hui avec des
témoignages pour la première fois des
victimes d'Occitanie à la barre
aujourd'hui et nous accueillons à la
galerie saravi à Montpellier une
exposition consacrée aux médiator et
merci à midi libre il faut rendre
dignité à ce qui ont subi la loi du
profit de Monsieur Servier
et qui ont été trompés voilà supplément
sur l'agriculture également dans Midi
Libre 16 pages autour de l'agriculture
d'Occitanie avec ses nombreux atouts
dont ceux évidemment de la métropole de
Montpellier merci
beaucoup d'être venu sur ce plateau
merci beaucoup Mickaël delarations
[Musique]